spirits
continue
good evening everybody this is a meeting
the planning and development management
Committee of Trafford Council apologies
for the delayed start you'll probably
see behind me we've got some technical
difficulties we're going to make a start
and we're going to um take some of the
applications to develop
um
so before we um
before we get started can I just check
is Mr bulmer here any chance yeah thank
you and is uh Jenka Catholic here yeah
okay thank you so we'll take that we'll
take that item first once we get to the
applications okay so um my name's
councilor Ben Hartley I'm the chair of
the committee I'm my immediate writers
councilor Barry win Stanley who's the
vice chair of the committee on our left
and right are offices from the council's
planning legal and highways team who are
here to advise the committee down the
tables along the side are local
councilors who are members of the
committee and I'll introduce those
people by name when they wish to speak
before we get started with the agenda
can I just check is anybody planning to
film any part of the meeting this
evening you could indicate now if you
are
no okay thank you so the meeting is is
being filmed and it's been live streamed
on the council's YouTube channel and a
recording of the meeting will be
available to view for a Time afterwards
as well
um we'll start with um item one agenda
which is attendances and apologies for
absence so we've had apologies from
councilor Walsh uh and there's no
substitute for him I don't think we've
had any other apologies it looks like
everybody else is is present so we'll
move on to item number two which is
Declarations of Interest so this is
members to give notice of any personal
or prejudicial interest and the nature
of that interest relating to any item on
the agenda in accordance with the other
two code of conduct any members looking
to make a declaration of Interest please
counselor Gwen Stanley ah thank you
chair yes I'll be accusing myself for
the 26 Hermiston main application this
is my family dentist thank you thank you
councilor Winston any other members
looking to declare any interests no okay
thank you ISO number three is the
minutes so it's the receive and if so
agreed to approve as a correct record
the minutes of the last meeting that was
held on the 9th of February uh 2023
um just think if you remember to move
those because I wasn't here councilor
Thomas
a cancellation
a second yeah thank you so those minutes
are um approved as a correct record of
that last meeting I've said number four
is questions from members of the public
so we have a maximum of 15 minutes
allocated to any public questions
submitted uh to democratic Services by 4
pm on the Working Day prior to the
meeting questions must be within the
remit of the committee or be relevant to
items appearing on the agenda and will
be submitted in the order received but
we've had no questions submitted for
this meeting
item number five is the additional
information report
um so copies are available in the room
and copies are emailed to members of the
committee earlier on today and we'll
consider the information in that report
as we look at each of the applications
so turning now to item number six
applications for permission to develop
um just by way of explanation for the
applications the process that will
follow uh is as follows first of all
we'll have a presentation from a member
of the planning team
we then may have speakers both against
and for an item each speaker will be
allowed three minutes and we will term
the contributions
um and I will give you a warning when
you're at the end of your time uh we
have local councilors who are here to
speak local councilors get up to five
minutes to speak on on any item when
we've heard from um
any speakers against them for uh the
item then members of the committee will
start to discuss that item I'll be
introduce them when they wish to make a
contribution and we do need to take a
vote on each item so you'll see us
taking a vote and we may have a number
of votes on certain applications
depending on what happens
so with that we'll move turn to the
first application and we first of all
we're going to consider application 109
463 which is the land at freshfields
fairy Lane in sale members of the
committee that starts on page 45 of your
bundle and we'll have an introduction
um from mislos thank you
thank you chair I apologies that
there'll be no visuals with this
presentation
and this is the application at the land
at freshfields on fairy Lane in sale and
the application is for a proposed energy
Reserve facility comprised of battery
energy storage system and ancillary
infrastructure
the application site is an open grass
Paddock in equestrian use within the
designated Green Belt the area is
characterized as an Urban Fringe
location and is located to the Eastern
edge of the Trafford Borough
the site is adjacent to the existing
sorry existing South Manchester
substation to the Northwest another
energy Reserve facility which is
currently under construction also to the
Northeast electricity pylons and other
energy infrastructure along with
telecommunications infrastructure and
the M60 Motorway is to the south of the
site and the Metrolink runs adjacent to
the southern boundary
so the Planning Commission is sought for
the construction of a battery energy
storage system with a capacity of 99.9
megawatts
these are systems that enable renewable
energy to be stored when Supply is high
higher than demand and released when
there are sages in this demand
there are 48 pairs of battery units
would be laid out across the site and
ancillary structures including small
buildings a substation and Landscaping
works are also proposed as well as an
acoustic fence on the north on part of
the north and Eastern boundaries
this application is reported to
committee as there are more than six
representations have been received
country to the officer recommendation
these representations predominantly cite
the construction impacts on the
surrounding hiring network of the
development and assumed fire risk and
the impact on residential amenity
these concerns have been considered and
addressed in the officer report to
committee and it is considered that
these can be dealt with by a suitably
worded conditions
The Proposal would constitute
inappropriate development in the green
belt which is by definition harmful to
the green belt and should only be
approved in very special circumstances
additional harm is also demonstrated to
the openness of the green belt and some
encroachment into the countryside
[Music]
there has been some identified harm to
visual amenity and temporary limited
harm to residential amenity through some
disturbance during the construction
phase
the introduction of additional
Landscaping has been sought
throughout the application processes
process and includes the introduction of
a planted landscape Bond and hedgerows
on the North and Eastern boundaries
adjacent to the 3.5 meter high acoustic
fence as a way to help screen and
improve the appearance of this part of
the development
[Music]
there are significant considerations in
favor of this proposal that hold very
significant weight
The Proposal would significantly
contribute to the local Regional and
National efforts to reduce the Reliance
on fossil fuels reduce greenhouse gas
emissions and Tackle climate change
the development incorporates an
Innovative technology to enable the
wider and effective application of
renewable energy
it would also increase Reliance on clean
energy and help to stabilize energy
storage and production being able to
respond quickly in less than a second to
local surges in electricity demand
the ecological value of the site will
also be improved through this
development with improved landscaping
and planting of native species with the
development achieving over 10
biodiversity net gain
in the consideration of this
applications officers have concluded
that the benefits of this development do
clearly outweigh the harms associated
and these benefits constitute very
special circumstances The Proposal is
considered to comply with policy R4 of
the core strategy and the mppf and is
therefore recommended for approval
subject to conditions thank you
thank you Miss loves Mr bulmer do you
want to come and have a seat just
opposite me please
thank you
um so if you just press the button on
the bottom of the microphone and the red
light should come on yeah that's great
yeah just make sure you're close to the
microphone just so everyone can is that
that's a moist yeah thank you
um so you'll you'll have three minutes
we'll start the clock when you start
speaking and if you run up to three
minutes I'll just ask you to wrap up
what you're saying okay thank you okay
thank you uh Professor lights uh
wish you could make a good evening thank
you for listening to me
I would like to start my objection with
proximity this battery storage facility
is far too close to my residence it is
30 meters from my front door and 10
meters from my front garden
the highest part of the development
which is a substation
is right next to my garden
the substation is visually oppressive it
looks like an electricity substation it
does not look nice
this will have a massive impact on my
family's View and our enjoyment of our
garden
the noise that this development will
make
and it will make it every day
for 365 days a year 24 hours a day
will massively impact my family's life
we won't be able to live with that my
family decided if this goes through we
have to move but then we're stuck
because no one wants to buy our house
it's too close
I'm not against these type of
developments whatsoever
and as the council will be aware there
are two further developments one is
planning permission in only last week
and another from the golf club which
will be put in in the next couple of
weeks for bigger developments in a
better place more hidden and I'm in full
favor of those two other developments
one is 200 megawatt and the other is 100
megawatt
this is right in the middle
it's next to my house right next to it
it's as the distance of this room
so you will see a substation less than
the distance of this room away from my
house when I sit in the garden 10 meters
is nothing
and for them reasons they're the reasons
I'm complaining
fairy Lane itself
is a private road a private Lane the
public have access but the speed limit
is 60 mile an hour
it's also only wide enough for one car
and a car has to move to pass all these
heavy Goods coming down this end of the
line where there is far more traffic
than Golf Road
is just going to cause utterly
not destruction of the lane but you
won't be able to get in and out when you
need to get out and this is going to go
on for two or three years
what else did I have
God likes to conclude there thank you
I'm very sorry to finish
thank you Mr Bowman yeah if you want to
take your seat at the back again please
thank you
uh and if we could have uh Janka kazlick
now please come and have a seat and
just make sure the microphone's on I
think it is and just bring yourself
close to the microphone that's great
yeah that's great yeah thank you and uh
yeah you'll have three minutes to speak
to us again thank you okay thank you
chairman
in order to meet the government's carbon
reduction targets under the climate
change act the energy balance is
becoming increasingly reliant on
renewable energy sources such as wind
and solder which can be intermittent and
unpredictable
this coupled with the phasing out of
fossil fuel power stations means there's
a growing need for new Power Solutions
that can respond quickly to local spikes
in demand and ensure a secure supply of
energy for the local network
with record levels of renewable energy
sources generating our power battery
storage can help us make the most of
this green energy using it to manage
Peaks and troughs in demand and operate
as efficiently as possible
the proposed system would have the
capacity to support approximately three
hundred thousand homes for up to two
hours at a time during periods of peak
demand
facilities must be located close to an
existing grid Supply point with both
Import and Export capacity
the South Manchester GSP is the only one
of the 17 in enw's Network that has the
required capacity available
in order to minimize translation Mission
losses and be economically viable sites
typically need to be located within a
kilometer of their connection
the only non-developed land within a
kilometer of the South Manchester GSP
Falls within a designated green belt
the site was selected due to its
proximity to the substation a willing
landowner limited ecological value and
compatible adjacent land uses including
the existing battery storage facility
that is at um on Mr boneless land to the
east of his property
it is also well screened and existing to
by existing topography and vegetation
and has a low probability of flood risk
Battery Technology is a clean energy
system and does not create emissions
detailed assessments have been
undertaken to support the application
and in all cases have confirmed that the
proposals would not result in any
unacceptable impacts
the very special circumstances that
would outweigh the low level of harm to
the green belt by reason of
inappropriateness has been demonstrated
this development would help to prevent
local power interruptions and would
therefore contribute to the local
economy by means of electricity security
whilst achieving a biodiversity net gain
of over 10 percent
it will also support increased renewable
energy generation contributing towards
net zero and reduced energy wastage
close to the existing substation capable
of being substantially screened by
existing and enhanced landscaping and
able to achieve noise levels that don't
exceed background at the closest
receptors the proposed development
provides a suitable site for this
facility which will provide vital backup
energy generation and balancing
capability to the local network
Trafford Council has declared a climate
emergency and is aiming for carbon
neutrality we hope that members can
follow their officer recommendation and
support this development which clearly
aligns with those aims
thank you thank you very much Miss
Catholic just like to return to your
seat
um before we get into debate I wonder if
we could just ask for some advice not
sure if it would be from Miss Lowe's or
Mr Everson just abandy
the impact of the of the traffic that Mr
Mr bulmer mentioned obviously I know
there's a proposed condition to manage
the construction phase but
um I wonder if there's any advice on the
specific point that Mr bulmer raised
about the fact that it's a single Track
Road and so the construction traffic is
is like to block access for residents
and other people using that road
all right
yeah thank you
yeah
um in terms of when we will process the
the application
um and we didn't believe that there was
any reason why we couldn't get
construction traffic along fairly Lane
um there is as you've mentioned there is
a condition related to the construction
uh management plan
um and if there are any difficulties
with some of the apparatus then it's not
uncommon in a lot of cases whereby they
do some accommodation works
um and we could do control that through
the construction management plan and
then put the those
undo those Works effectively and
potentially
um that's not not uncommon it's part of
the works if it is deemed that some of
the plants may have difficulties getting
getting to the site
um it often happens with wind farms and
the likes particularly out in this type
of environment so we didn't feel that
was a problem
thank you that is useful thank you
um
any members of the committee looking to
speak on this item please
Chancellor Wilson
thank you um I I it's it's really tricky
when we have these developments that are
close close to residential
um properties I can very much understand
why somebody wouldn't want something
like this built very close uh to their
house
um
obviously I think and it is Greenbelt
Land uh it sounds like this has a there
is a strong purpose behind this a
special a very special reason for
building on the green belt so you know
with this particular case I think it's a
good reason for building on the Green
Belt we're going if we're going to do it
um ever you know it is being done for
all the right reasons
um looking at the
you know looking at the the section on
residential amenity it's the the
committee report suggests that the
suggests that the screening
um will
mitigate the visual aspects plus the
sound
so which would suggest that there's not
you know whilst there is inevitably
going to be an impact on the residence
residential immunity it's not going to
be great enough for us to as a committee
to justifiably reject this application
without you know without the
Justified fear that we would be
overturned if this went to appeal
um I can't see any
issue that would you know that that
would be strong enough
um for it for for that to happen for
that
um for it not to get turned over later
on uh so I think on balance I'm Pro I'm
uh I will be voting in favor of this
development I think
and I would be happy to propose it thank
you
thank you thank you Council Wilson
cancer Thomas
thank you chair which is a definitely a
cash 22 situation with uh the the
benefits of the best
uh against Green Green Belt Building on
uh I have strong sympathies I haven't
looked at the the side layout with Mr
Bulma
um in terms of where the the uh
Transformer is cited I do wonder whether
or not there is a a potential to to
re-look at the plan not the the build up
and move the Transformer to
uh the further Corner
um
which is further away from from his
property they picked the corner that is
is closest to the property of Mr Bulma
having said that I'm not an electrical
electrical mechanical engineer or
designer so I'm not sure that is
possible there are reports that I don't
think we've seen that need to be put
forward in terms of the tram Network
tgfm the
done record scene so I mean that's still
in the air but uh again I'm leaning
towards uh
accepting the officer's decision
um but I would like if possible for the
uh
the design to to be looked at and see
whether or not that is
a small movement that the development
can take to
perhaps uh lessen any impact on on
residential immunity thank you
thank you Council Thomas cancel a minute
got a huge amount of sympathy for
um residents nearby
um to have this this nearby near them
built near them but I also understand
the need for storage of electricity
um
and
so that we can keep so we can store it
if we're going to have renewable energy
we need to
um collect it when like say for example
solar panels in the daytime and then
release it for the night time usage
um and beekeeping that you're going to
say evening hours Etc so I think that
there's there is need and it is
something that actually I I would say
that green belt development is actually
probably some probably the correct use
for it
um but yes huge amount of sympathy for
Neighbors I don't know um yes similar to
council Thomas if there's any way of
mitigating and trying to lessen the harm
then that would be great but ultimately
I'll I'll be voting in favor and and
happy to Second
um Council Walton's proposal thank you
thank you councilman I send any of the
members looking to speak
and I think what I would say is that I
mean I I agree with councilor Wellston
and councilman I'm happy to vote in
favor of this development
um
there's obviously a lot of comments from
from neighboring residents but these are
going to be a feature of the landscape
in years to come we're going to need a
lot more of these facilities to
um store electricity as we move towards
renewable sources and and actually I
think this is not a bad site for for
this sort of facility I think in terms
of the noise which Mr former mentioned
there are and I think the report says to
so clearly there are quite high levels
of background noise anyway because it's
close to the M60 and the Metrolink and
there's another facility being built to
the northeast of Mr bulma's property
um which I think indeed so in the report
it says that is 90 meters to the
Northeast presumably that's from this
application site
and I think Mr Bowman's house sits
between this application site and that
facility so there's already noise from a
similar facility albeit a smaller one in
in that area so um I do have sympathy
for for the fact that it's been built
right near Mr sort of Boomers
property but I um actually in terms of
the impact on the wider area I think
this is this is a good site for this
sort of facility so I'll be voting in
favor myself Council Thomas you wanted
to say something else yeah sorry just to
clarify uh it's the EMV report on
Electro Wang that's it
I think with the thing and I'm I'm
assuming that will be uh either in place
before anything starts and on that note
I will note he's not been yet I'll
second Council welton's proposal
all right
thank you yeah I think councilman is
seconded it but um could we um Mr Lowes
do we do we have any more information
about the the EV report that the
Metrolink and the possible interference
I think the BMC yes so there's two
conditions on
um the the decision that would require
them to be submitted and there's one
that there's a report that needs to be
because
submitted prior to operation and then if
there's any variation in the
electromagnetic magnetic charges to come
in second so there's a kind of doubling
um Security on on that part of it so we
have those two conditions that cover
that
thank you Miss Lowe's any of the members
look at speaking this item councilor
Proctor thank you chair it's it's a
question
um
I'm sorry it's gone totally out of my
head just give me a minute
[Music]
any of the members looking to speak
whilst uh
let me see what cancel the price wants
to ask okay councilor Winston sorry
cancer proxy I've remembered
I'm sorry
when I've read about the noise levels
that
um the battery installation will produce
they're lower than the noise from the
M60 and the
um Metrolink that's correct yeah and
then my other question was can we put a
condition in
so that
um lorries don't
go to the site around school opening and
closing times is that possible
it is I think there is a condition to
that effect already I'll just come to
miss Lowe's just to give some advice on
that on your first question you're
correct the background noise levels and
that exist and the noise that will be
generated from the development would be
lower than that and it's actually not
the batteries that create any noise it's
the fans that kill them and and on the
second question there's a construction
management plan and added a condition
added which specifies that no hgv
movements shall take place during
um School pick-off pick up and drop-off
times and specifies and set
um hours when they can't take place
thank you miss those any of the members
looking to speak
Hassan hey thank you it is really a very
uh it's no problem to favor this
application but the gentleman was
speaking against this application saying
it's about how many meters is 10 10
meters away from his property right so
all we need to do is make make sure that
he
the president's safety mental and mental
health is very important and try to make
sure we can do more
the best thing we can do the burst
things in regards to mitigate the noise
this is all I want to say
that's it
thank you counselors and there is there
is some information in the additional
info report I think about further uh
Landscaping which I think
um
will have a an additional
um benefit on the noise reduction as I
understand it
um okay any of the members looking to
speak it has been moved and seconded it
we we Grant planning permission in
accordance with the recommendation so
I think we'll move to vote on that then
all those in favor of granting
permission as per office recommendation
okay and anyone against
okay that is unanimous so permission is
granted for that application and thank
you for the speakers who came to speak
on this item
so
foreign
we've still got technical difficulties
with the um the screen behind us so
um
what Miss curly is just advising me is
that they can print copies of the
presentation and we could probably do
one between two if those members who've
got their laptop with them which I
haven't we can it can also be emailed to
you so you can you can look at it on
your own laptop if that's a benefit so
should we do that yeah okay
oh okay yeah um who if you just let me
know if you've got a laptop or a device
to to look at it on and then miss Milne
can email to you
okay
thank you
come on
okay
um thank you can I just check if Rachel
McDowell is here please yeah and is uh
Zoe Reynolds here as well please yeah
okay so we'll move on to that item now
so it's um application 109 856
which is 299 Ashley Road in Hale that
starts on page 82 of the bundle and
we'll start with a
um an introduction from Ms Milner thank
you
thank you chair this application site
relates to a large um recently
constricted residential property set
back from Ashley Road we've been
spacious ground
the majority of the site is within the
green belt with only a small
um northern section of the site and
partially covering the house and outside
the green belt
parts of the site is designated for a
wildlife Courier Corridor area for
protection of landscape character and to
the South and
River Valley flood Lanes with land
levels dropping towards the river valley
there was an existing track running from
Ashley Road along the northern edge of
the site which provides access to the
properties of 295 297 and 299 Ashley
Road with 299 being the application
property
the proposed development relates to the
southern part of the property cartilage
and an area of grassland formally a
paddock the site is currently accessed
by a single Lane shared track from
Ashley Road The Proposal is to construct
a new private way and the erection of
fencing Gates and Associated Landscaping
during the construction of the property
and that is now on site a track was
installed for construction traffic
this application is for a permanent Farm
style track on the same route
um although it would have a slightly
reduced width I think from 4.9 sorry
from 5.2 to 4.9
it would have a central grass Verge
planted
um with no curbs or edging and the
access would become the main access
route for 299 Ashley Road although the
existing shared access would be retained
it's also to propose to replace the
existing
cattle grid at the Ashley road entrance
with a continuation of the existing
coupled sets in addition it's proposed
to a small section of
um Timber fencing
um on the south of the Ashley road
entrance and also
um
Cheshire estate railings adjacent to the
Timber and Timber fence and around the
proposed access track at the Eastern end
of the access track a new section of
estate railing
um the state railing fencing is also
proposed
is considered that the proposed access
track would constitute a minor
engineering access operation and the
fencing would have no harmful impact on
the openness of the green belt and would
not impact on the any of the five
purposes of the green belt in line with
the mppf as such it's acceptable in
principle in regards to the green belt
furthermore the proposed track pertains
a rural character in keeping with the
context of the site and the open
Countryside failed the property
the additional fencing and Gates
um in estate railings are considered to
be keeping the character of the site
and it's also considerable
to have a considerable impact on
residential amenity
and not impact and harmfully impact the
Outlook or privacy of neighboring
properties
and objections received are noted and
just to confirm as detailed within the
air and the impact on the existing trees
is considered to be minor and has been
given limited weight but there will be
no harm to the trees on site
therefore on balance it's could consider
that the proposal is in accordance with
national policy in regards to Greenbelt
and local policy within the mppf and
householder development therefore
subject to conditions we do recommend
approval
thank you Miss Miller
um
Mr McDowell do you want to come and have
a seat just opposite me please
[Music]
so I think the microphone is still on so
just make sure you're close to the
microphone so we can pick up on what you
hear uh can you hear me yes
um so you'll have three minutes to speak
to us and if you run up to three minutes
I'll just ask you to start to wrap up
your remarks please okay thank you
okay uh good evening I'm Rachel McDowell
of 295 Ashley Road and I'm objecting to
the planning applications submitted by
Mr and Mrs Jones on behalf of 10
households the site lies within the in
Greenbrook in Greenbelt where
development is only allowed in certain
limited scenarios we consider that the
development will harm the appearance and
openness of the area and will lead to
encroachment of the countryside there is
no justification for the development so
since there's an existing permanent
access owned by 299
as part of the construction of the new
house the council agreed to the creation
of a temporary access road for
construction traffic condition 11 of the
planning permission dated November 2019
required that this access be permanently
closed and reinstated in the interest of
visual immunity and impact on the
openness of the green belt this was
reimposed in 2022 nothing has changed
the condition is still valid
the photos included within our objection
letter show the significant visual
changes which will result should this
development be allowed the existing Road
was aligned to maintain the open aspect
while the proposed Road cuts through the
paddock having an urbanizing effect
the photo montage submitted subsequently
by the applicant shows a
computer-generated artist's impression
of a view sometime in the future with
mature trees this is not a fair
reflection there is a grave concern that
if permission is granted it's highly
likely the proposed track will be
upgraded over time to become a more
formal Road the planning history on site
shows how non-material Amendments have
been used
the planning officers report States the
track will have no impact on the Outlook
of the closest Residential Properties
creating a new Road in the open field
spoils the visual immunity as a present
traffic is well screened by a large head
hedge the temporary road is often used
for parking by visitors to the site
we are concerned about the unaddressed
impact the road will have on the
capacity and functionality of the
floodplain additional information
provided tonight has confirmed that the
existing track will remain in use for
299 The Proposal is for the Eastern end
of the track to be gated not closed off
giving the applicant a circular in and
out route
archery advisor considered that there
will be no material benefit to the trees
from reducing the traffic from one house
on the existing road again additional
information provided this evening
changes the officer's report to give
only limited weight to any benefit on
the drive for the trees it will still be
used by 299
finally we do not believe a householder
application is the appropriate route for
this application because the paddock
does not form part of the domestic
cartilage of the property cold appeals
access stating to 2019 clearly
identified that the area was not part of
the domestic cartilage in summary the
proposed development cannot be
considered appropriate development due
to the impact it would have on the
landscape extending the urban edge of
the settlement into a previously
undeveloped open area of paddock
adjoining the River Bowling it would be
highly visible from Ashley Road and as
such would harm the visual immunity of
the area there is no need for the
development given the presence of the
existing Road
thank you Ms McDowell if you just want
to return to your seat please
and uh
sorry Reynolds have you could um come
and take the seat opposite me please
um
and again you'll have three minutes and
we'll start a timer once you start to
speak okay thank you thank you good
evening chair members of the planning
committee this application proposes to
utilize existing construction access
which has been in place for over three
and a half years to become the main
access for the occupiers in the form of
a private way
the private way has been designed to
have a farm truck style appearance the
central grass Verge and will have no
curves and edges
I set out in the officer report it has
been accepted that the proposal
constitutes minor engineering Works
which is considered appropriate in the
green belt
the proposed access adjoins the existing
shared access with 295 and 297 Ashley
Road
the post also have no impact on highway
safety and the council's highways team
has raised no objection
it's been considered in the office
report that the proposal has a positive
impact on trees the council's tree
officer supports the production of
traffic across the root protection areas
of the veteran and mature trees along
with shared access
the officer's report also considers the
proposal will not harm the character of
the curtisage of 299 Ashley Road
and would be acceptable in terms of its
impact of residential immunity
to facilitate the private way minor
Amendments have exist in fencing and
gates are proposed with new fencing
gates to much existing
Cobblestone sets are to be extended at
the entrance of the shared access and
main entrance Gates 299 Ashley Road
these Works will be these Works will be
royal and character and will be in
keeping with the Royal setting
overall the principal development has
been considered acceptable and will not
impact the openness of the green belt
and Rural character other properties
cartilage
the proposal has a positive impact on
existing trees as acceptable in terms of
Highways and residential immunity
I hope that you can agree with the
officer's recommendation for approval
and are mine to support the application
thank you
thank you Miss Reynolds if you want to
return to your seat thank you for
speaking to us
um
Miss Miller I just wonder if I could ask
for some advice on something that uh Ms
McDowell mentioned which was around
um a fear that the track that's proposed
might be upgraded in the future to
something more substantial
um obviously the current appearance is
described as sort of a farm track which
which it does look like
if the if the applicant did want to
upgrade something more substantial what
would happen then would that require new
application
yes it would as with the original with
the original planning application for
the house we removed permitted
development for the entire site
um and so
in terms of where we are now if they
were to upgrade further they would
require consent
um
so yeah
thank you any members looking to speak
on this item cancel the chalking
uh thank you chair so
um I do know the site it's around the
corner from my house
um
I I it's a tricky one because I can see
where the officers
are coming from in in their report
um but I also sympathize with the
residence uh I love those houses the
Outlook from those houses is great and
it's it this road putting a driveway
there would spoil it so I do sympathize
with the argument that there is an
impact on their immunity there but my
principal problem with this is actually
traffic related
um I know highways have raised in our
objection but that entrance is
it's a blind entrance
um you don't know whether you're coming
out of it or whether you're going into
it you've no idea what's that
um
the way the drivers is currently
configured now it forces if you're
coming out of those properties you're
forced to come into a slow speed
um the danger of putting in a long
straight Road
and I'm gonna I'm gonna sound a bit
stupider but the the danger of putting a
bit a long straight Road in a house of
that type knowing what vehicles go with
houses of that type
um it just means that you're risking a
car coming speeding out it straight onto
Ashley Road in my mind
um creating a very significant traffic
rest there a highways risk so I'm not
managed to support it on that basis I
know it's fairly it's it's maybe fairly
weak but I can't
I can't support us on that just because
of that
um Welcome to our other thoughts
thank you thank you Council talking
um Council service I wonder if I could
just come to you for the point that can
on the point that counselor chalk can
raise just about what assessment was
done of the high risk risk through
having that new entrance point or it
being made a permanent entrance Point as
opposed to a temporary one
in terms of the the points raised
um there are gates to control the the
speed potentially in terms of coming
straight out
I would have imagined it can happen
but equally the people are using it are
aware that the junction is there first
of all
um in terms of the access it is already
there and whilst it may not
meet the full requirements it's it's
already it's already an access with an
access ultimately if it's not granted
this they will have their existing
situation
so it was D it was judged on on what was
before us ultimately
um but yeah potentially anyone on a
straight section of Road
should they wish they they could
potentially speed
um there's not a lot we can
unfortunately do about that but the the
site the access is already there so we
have to judge what whether or not if it
was a brand new access then in terms of
visibility and those issues that would
be a completely different situation and
we would have to judge it on on that
many but it already has it already is an
access and will be an access even if
this is not granted in this in this form
so that's the why we we judge what we
judge it on not necessarily meeting the
full criteria I'm afraid
thank you Mr Everson uh councilor Welton
thanks chair
um special circumstances for for
building on the Green Belt I can't see
them I can't see them here
um you might maybe you can update me on
that um in in a bit but there's already
a road
um you know that that goes to the
property so do we need another one I
don't buy the uh the argument in the
offices report that this is a Country
Lane
um because it's right you know in most
country lanes don't run parallel to
another road that goes in exactly the
same direction you know it's not it's a
Country Lane is on its own
surrounded by lots of fields you know
and it's that's the one that's the the
one lane that you you know you you get
to to use this is in effectively
extending the urban sprawl no matter
what what it looks like now you know um
you know they might be trying to dress
it up as a Country Lane but it's you
know this is this is a a property that's
built been built on the edge of an urban
area and creating another access path
extends that
um access track extends that urban area
you know that's the the fact of the
matter I can't I I can't see this as
just a a Country Lane in the countryside
it it it seems you know a very
convenient argument this is Greenbelt
lands we need special circumstances I
can't see a special circumstance
thank you thank you councilor Welton I'm
just going to ask for some advice on
that point because my understanding was
that
um very special circumstances don't need
to be demonstrated here because
the proposed development doesn't
um offend one of the purposes of green
belt but I'll ask Miss Milner to advise
in a clear away than I've just done
not necessarily offend the purpose of
the green belt but it's more about
whether it's considered to be an
exception and not form inappropriate
development within the green belt so
we've assessed it as an engineering
operation which wouldn't be
inappropriate development within the
green belt and therefore the very
special circumstances that you're
referring to it's a it's a different
exception so we're not looking at very
special circumstances we're saying it's
not inappropriate development in the
green belt as an engineering operation
I can
so within the mppf it sells out and for
assessing proposals within the green
belt it says inappropriate development
is by definition
um harmful to the green belt and should
only be allowed in very special
circumstances
but then it sets out
that there were certain types of
development that are not classed as
inappropriate development
and there's a there's a big list
um so for example buildings for
agriculture and extensions that aren't
disproportionate in size
um even Limited in filling in villages
and it also goes on to say there are
other exemptions such as
um
public transport infrastructure
engineering operations that's two
separate points
um and material changes of land so
the test of whether those special
circumstances is needed is only if it's
considered any appropriate development
once you move it out of the
inappropriate development category into
what is appropriate development you do
not need very special circumstances
there's already an access track for this
property
yeah so you're you're effectively
duplicating what's there already so I
mean I I don't understand how that isn't
it just because it's an engineering
function what you know
this seems like you know it seems like a
real attempt to to find a reason to to
justify this whereas
it's you justify the unjustifiable I
suppose really
uh I I can't you know
this is the this is
sorry this is our assessment obviously
as the decision makers it will be for
you to consider whether you consider it
to to fall within um
appropriate or inappropriate development
and therefore whether the tests are
necessary but from our assessment we've
concluded it would be an engineering
operation
okay thank you Miss Miller cancer
akinola
can I just clarify so that they exist
there is a track that's already used
but they've made a temporary one and
it's the temporary one they want to make
into a permanent one and that's what
they're getting permission they're
asking permission for
yeah
yeah so what happens if there isn't
permission given what happens to the
temporary one and is all the land that's
being used is it does it belong to I
know that's it doesn't matter in
planning terms who the land belongs to
but
I'm just interested
if this permission isn't granted they
would still be required for to remove
the um the track
so the track at the moment is just a
construction track if it doesn't get
permission to be permanent they would
then be in under
um
the condition would require that it's
it's still removed
And in regards to land ownership yes
this is
um within the ownership of the applicant
so with it being a track then at the
moment I can't remember seeing anything
about tarmac I can't remember what it
said about the ground bit
it's mud at the minute but it's not
going to stay mud though is it
it's um
so
so it's horrible taking out a grid
paragraph 10.
[Music]
so I think it's going to be uh questions
yeah and with grass a grass Burge in the
middle
examples
um
did you have anything else you wanted to
say okay okay thank you uh I'll come to
counselor when Stanley now please
thank you chair I can't don't think I
can vote for this
um I don't I think the
the arguments about the Galaxy the green
belt I think it's very very finely
balanced
I don't think this is required for the
access to the to the new house I think
they've already got the access and the
idea of building of making permanent
construction track
um which runs across the green belt
which could impact on the visual
amenities of the people who are already
there but also
it's the green belt so I don't think I
can be vote of this so I will be voting
against officer recommendation thank you
chair
thank you Council Winston uh councilor
Thomas did you want to speak thank you
it the terminology we're using Country
Lane is basically a driveway to the to
the home it's it's nothing more than
that if you go down there today and have
a look at Jazzy's you wouldn't see
anything particularly out of place you
would think oh there's a driveway down
to a big house at the back
um the mound of Earth that has to go and
my point of view is that when this was
put in there was probably an idea to put
this premium application forward and it
would have perhaps served them better to
have done that at the first place but as
it is
the the road is there the impact through
the trees from the June 95 and 297 is
minimal it's a residency it's not going
to be a thoroughfare there's going to be
four or five cars going up there perhaps
once or twice a day so the amenity
that's lost is is negligible it's going
to have
um the the the Grass Center track so if
I want to have a better word so
I I actually support the officer's
recommendation to Grant and I'm quite
happy to prose as such purely and simply
because it is in situ if we're going
across uh grasses to each side of this
road then I'd have a different Outlet
Outlook but it is there and it is in
place and it doesn't look out of place
from from my my thinking so without
support thank you councilor Thomas
councilor minutes
thank you chair I think if it wasn't
green belt I'd be more tempted to say
it's okay but I think you've already got
access there I don't think it's
necessary and I think it just ends up
you just end up concreting on more green
space and it's unnecessary so um it's
not concrete it's modern moment and so I
think that um I can't I can't support it
I'll be proposing actually that we
refuse
um refuse the application and go against
office and recommendation
given that I I know that it's
apparently appropriate development on
the green melt but I did I don't think
it's necessary and I think it's
I think it personally think it's
inappropriate I get that it's a class I
get what the classification is I
understand what you're saying but I
don't think it's necessary to think that
this it just lands up
um destroying
um what greens what green space is there
and it's almost like a eventually it
could be a creeping form of development
thank you
I yeah thank councilman so I don't we
always need to be careful at committee
meetings not to
um speculate or give any weight to the
motivations of an applicant so I don't I
don't think it's a relevant
consideration for us to say that the
driveway isn't necessary it's up to the
applicant if they want to apply for that
form of development they can and it's
for us to think about in planning terms
whether that's acceptable development or
not so I don't think we can question
whether it's necessary in the same way
that we wouldn't question whether
somebody building an extension to get an
extra bedroom is necessary we would say
your entitled to make the application
um but but I but I hear what you're
saying about the the impact on on the
Green Belt um
thank you chair
they've already done it
without planning permission
well there's a muddy Lane
that's been dug on the pictures that I'm
looking at
yeah so
I just
there's already an access route they
don't need another one and it's
I don't see that the
purpose fit apart from destroying what's
a nice field
and
yeah I just don't think it's necessary I
can't I can't support this I'll be
voting against it
so um I'll turn to miss Cole if some
advice now particularly on the on the
Green Belt designation and and
development that's maybe permitted there
thank you chair
um greenbelts are not an environmental
designation they're a land use
designation
they don't have to have any biodiversity
interest or any environmental interest
um sometimes those two things go
together sometimes they don't
um their purpose is set out in the mppf
they are intended to maintain openness
um and equally
um it's understood and has been
understood in uh planning policy at
local and National for since they
existed that some some things can and
should
happen in the Green Belt being green
belt is not a bar on development it is a
bar on certain types of development
again you can you can justify those
through various special circumstances as
we found earlier this evening
um
the this is an engineering operation
um I can understand why members think it
might not be necessary but that's not
for questioning I don't think you can
question either whether it's an
engineering operation or not I think
that's a matter of fact
um and you need to behave reasonably in
your decision making whatever your sort
of gut feeling about this is whatever
your gut feeling about green belts are
so it is an appropriate form of
development in the green belt it's also
a track so it's flat so the impact on
openness is always going to be extremely
limited and there are other things that
that come with it that are set out in
the officer report
so
your decision making this evening should
be about what green belts are in
planning terms and what the those
exceptions are not not on an idea that
green green belt should never be built
on because that is not their purpose and
that is not why they're why they are
designated
I hope that's been helpful
thank you Miss Kelly
um councilor Morgan see you next time
uh thank you chair I'm I'm happy to
Second uh councilman Minister's uh
proposal to proposes I don't think this
is appropriate development Green Belt um
and I I mean I live opposite a country
track it is Muddy so in the winter it
gets cars it goes to a farm because it's
cars which get money this won't um it is
it is a road it's a driveway
um and yeah I I won't be supporting this
this evening thank you
thank you councilor Morgan um councilor
bunting you wanted to speak yes thank
you chairman I'm going to agree with
councilor Thomas I think Andy officers
um
the as has been pointed out the this is
not this for reasons which she officers
have already explained this is uh not an
inappropriate development uh the
engineering operation is a it's not for
us to go and say oh well that piece of
law I don't agree with or that piece of
rule for those are the rules that exist
and this Falls within one of those
categories and therefore they're allowed
they're making their application uh also
there's been a great deal spoken about
oh is it needed or obviously it's not a
committee of needs it's not a committee
it's justify whether somebody deserves
something or they don't deserve
something or they should be allowed to
have it they shouldn't be allowed to
have it we simply deal with the
applications and do they comply with the
regulations that exist there is also a
great deal in the uh objections about
all this could happen or that could
happen or this might happen in the
future or there's a precedent for this
or a precedent for that and as we all
know Burano precedence in planning each
application is dealt with them inside
merits and we can't deal with what might
or might not happen at some undefined
point in the future so so I can see and
there's also to point out the very
obvious Mrs Cody has also pointed out
about his flat uh yes absolutely it is
and therefore the impact upon the green
belt and the openness is is very minimal
so there is no real uh planning reason
to refuse this application uh if we do
go ahead and refuse it it's straight to
appeal job and I I would be amazed if
the inspector doesn't just overturn the
application the decision that we've made
so on those grounds chairman I can see
uh no reason not to support the uh
proposal already made by councilor
Thomas and I will be voting in favor of
Officer recommendation thank you thank
you councilor bunting councilor Hassan
all right thank you uh I don't think
there is any green belt issue here
because uh I mean only the applicant
asking for an attack sex I don't think
is a public road that we bought I'm very
fully agreed my Council uh Thomas has
said very comprehensively explained
things that there is no encroachment
issue at all and there is no
Horticultural issue at all and it is and
Miss goli has just explained about the
uh the green bag and it is nothing to do
with the green bed at all I mean we have
studied it and and it is an XX the road
is already existing there it is an
access to uh to to the property the
applicant so I will fully support this
application this is no problem at all
thank you
thank you counselor San
um councilor Thomas I'll come back to
you and then counselor Welton and then I
think we probably need to move to
suburbs thank you
thank you chair yeah it was just
basically to to I can't think of any
planning reason why we can refuse this
as Council Bluffton said enough in the
debate that I've heard I've not heard
one considering what's in the report and
the additional information that we've
been given uh by Miss Coley I've just
I've not heard one reason that we can
actually refuse this application other
than and other than the amenity and the
amenities shielded by trees it will not
impact on anybody's immunity looking
over a green belt field at all and other
than that I cannot think of any other
valid reason to refuse
[Music]
foreign
by the token of anything you know an
engineering construction being permitted
to be be built and can't be regarded as
the Green Belt that means that you could
just build any track anywhere on the
green belt at any time
is that the case is it the absolutely
new planning way of stopping that can I
ask
generally yes tracks are Farm tracks and
that kind of thing granted planning
permission for many of them over the
years yes because they're because they
don't impact on openness it's not a farm
track though is it it's not going to
default well usually on Open Fields you
it would be it would be a farm track
usually they're tar marked so more uh
sort of harder materials
you've not been around the Farms are
boating like I am
okay I think I think that I mean for my
part I'm I'm happy with the application
I'll be I'll be voting in in favor of
granting it when we come to the votes
and and I think that last point is
particularly prescient that you you know
farmers are quite quite routinely will
create new access to fields and and
they'll be right you know it'll be
gravel or it might be tarmacred I I you
know I agree with councilor Thomas I
think this is designed in such a way
sort of looks like a farm track
appreciate serving a property but um I
don't think whether you whether your
label this is a driver or a track really
really matters at all it's to do with
the the impact of that on uh on the
green belt and I and I agree with
councilor Thomas I don't think this is
an inappropriate form of development for
the green belt it doesn't affect the
openness of the green belt and so I'm
I'm quite happy with it um but it's it's
been moved and seconded that we refuse
planning permission
um so we will vote on uh we need to um
yeah so uh I'm just thinking who
proposed against cancer
Ministry proposed refusing and councilor
Morgan you seconded it so um I don't
know if one of you wants to advance some
reasons for refusal please
um for me it was the fact that it's I
think if it wasn't Green Belt I would
have said yes and the fact that it is
green belt I understand when you're
saying that and the engineering thing I
just don't I'm afraid I can't I can't
agree with the principle of of putting
um tarmac on
um green melt land when it's not
necessary at all
sorry not to unlock but the point is I
can't see I can't see the need to put
something solid effectively on you know
it it you land up going down the road of
iron sand Farms have tracks and I'm not
disagreeing that you know when you go
walking through around Farms but you
wouldn't build this through a park you
wouldn't have cars going through
well
it's actually not part
tracks go not not vehicles
um going on
they don't not parks where people are
going to in Greece spaces okay I
disagree I don't think it's an it's it's
um a necessary
thing you have access already to the
property if you didn't have access I
would say yes fine
um the absence that are given you have
an access to property already I don't
see why this is needed at all and I
therefore but whilst it's there in in
the it falls into the yes acceptable
form of development I agree I disagree
that it's needed so okay
it is green belts so
we've already covered we've already
covered the facts we've already covered
the fact that um it's not a we've
already covered against some minutes if
we could move the debate on please we've
already covered the fact that this is
not about necessity so we wouldn't
refuse somebody wanted to build uh an
extension with an extra bedroom by
saying well you don't need four bedrooms
three is fine so we wouldn't do that so
it's not it's not about necessity um but
I'm gonna uh turn to miss Milne now for
some advice which may help us
I think you your best course of action
is probably to say it would be
detrimental to
um visual amenity and character I think
um from what you're saying if we put the
green bell argument to one side I think
you'd be talking about the visual
amenity argument I'm happy to go with a
visual immunity if that's what we have
to put down as a reason thank you
okay
um councilor Morgan is there anything
you happy with that
happy today
thank you councilor Morgan
um you've spoken several times already
councilor welcome so I'm okay
um is it is it possible that this could
affect the I mean you talk about the own
openness of the green the green belt but
this is creating artificial boundaries
you know borders within the green belt
dividing up that field into twos which
is which is affecting the openness of
the green belt surely can that not be
included as a reason
I think you're still then swaying into
the green belt argument I think that
would you're talking about you can still
talk about visual amenity and character
and you could talk about
you could expand on that reason in
regards to the the open character of the
site and the subdivision for a track
if the Swiss goes to appeal that would
be your
machine that's what you're you're yeah
so we'd include that within that'd be
covered in the visual amenity and
character
and harm to character
Okay so we've got our suggested reasons
for refusal so let's move to the vote on
the refusal motion first so this is to
refuse uh planning permission against
the recommendation from officers as well
those in favor of refusal if you could
raise your hand now please
okay and all those against refusal
please
[Music]
okay
okay I never vote on the uh this is to
approve planning permissions all those
in favor of approval raise now please
and all those uh against approval please
[Music]
with the sixth
it's all right so that has been refused
so the refusal motion was was carried
and the approval was not so permission
for that application is refused
thank you
so thank you for your patience everyone
the next application we'll look at is uh
number one one double zero nine three
Longford Park starts on page one three
two of your bundle and we'll start with
the uh an introduction from Miss Milner
thank you
do members have a presentation in front
of them
has been emailed and there are hard
copies
um
anybody speaking for against Longford
park there is a hard copy available
um on the desk so you might want to look
for it as we speak so you can follow
laughs
so this application relates to Longford
Park in Stratford Longford Park is a mid
to late 19th century Design park
landscape and the remaining built Legacy
of John and Henry Carter rylands with
much of the park performing the grounds
of the now demolished Longford Hall the
land was purchased by Stratford Urban
District Council in 1911 from the
rylands estate and was opened as a
public park in 1912 whilst Longford Hall
was demolished in 1995 a number of
important buildings and features remain
which connect the park to its history
Longford Park was designated as a
conservation area in 1996 in recognition
of the area's contribution to Stratford
social and cultural history
The Proposal seeks a package of
improvement Works to be carried out
across the park which is subject to a
Heritage Lottery funding bid and a
variety of other funding streams
the HLF bid sorry the Heritage Lottery
funding bid seeks to support projects
that connect people and communities to
the net to their National regional and
local heritage
the need for Park improvements has been
in the planning for a number of years
and public consultation has been
undertaken from 2020 and with extensive
consultation in 2022 also the plans have
been worked up with ongoing consultation
with the friends of local of Longford
Park
officers acknowledge given the extent of
the work proposed and the staging the
funding round that further detail is
required to secure the package of
improvements envisaged in the submission
and the conditions listed within the
report and the additional information
report seek to secure that high quality
scheme
there are proposals relate to all areas
of the park including repairs and
alterations to the former Longford Hall
footprint Larry Sullivan Gardens the
Portico and the haha restoration of the
Lombard for Community use and
restoration and improvements to park
entrances the formal Gardens the world
Gardens
and all of the areas of the park the
main issue is to consider a Heritage
residential amenity impacting the
protected open space highways and
parking ecology and Landscaping so if
you look at your presentation and the
first
slide is is it's just the boundary of
the the park the master plan kind of
covers the all the areas of the park and
I'll just quickly run through
um what this cup is so in regards to the
sports pitches there's no loss of sports
pitches in fact the football pitches at
the the northeastern side are being
reconfigured to um to be moved up
slightly to allow for a cricket pitch to
be put in place and the cricket pitch
will be grasped but there will be a um a
wicket in the middle an artificial
wicket
and they'll also be improvements to the
tennis courts and the Youth Sports area
and along with basketball courts so
that's on the next page with photographs
of the existing
um
then we move up to the western side of
the park and this is where you'll have
the pump track so this is a bike path
there's there's two two of them proposed
one for smaller children and one for
older children
then we've got improvements to both play
areas the North and South that are cater
for different age children we've got the
Wii configuration
um of pets corner and improvements to
pets corner and we've got improvements
to the outdoor space around the cafe
improvements to the disc golf area so
signage wayfinding and Boundary
treatment and improvements to all
entrances
and
changes to the car park there's also
upgrades to
um footpaths throughout
um and then you've got you move on to
the the grand lawn and the haha
and then pictures other Portico and the
the footprint as
um as is at the moment we've also see
improvements to the Long Barn and the
outdoor space around the shipon building
and they'll be upgrade to lighting
in the park
and then
um
the book
um that currently runs through the park
will be deculpited so it'll be opened up
um and it'll be visible throughout the
park so that's quite an extensive fit of
engineering
it is acknowledged that some elements of
The Proposal including the installation
of additional sports facilities
introduction of lighting columns and
alterations to the Long Barn will resort
resort in minor harm to the character
and appearance of Longford Park
Conservation Area
this is considered to be at the lower
end of lesson substantial in regards to
the mppf and other works including the
reinstatement of historical routes and
improved Heritage interpretation
of the original Hall represents
substantial Heritage benefits When
undertaking the balancing exercise
required within the mppf and this is
considered to outweigh the less than
substantial harm
in addition to significant public
benefits this is therefore considered to
be acceptable in Heritage terms The
Proposal seeks to retain all existing
sporting and recreational facilities
with the addition of a new quicker pitch
and pump track whilst the creation of
the pump track and meticulous velocity
in some areas of open open and informal
recreational space within the park it is
considered that this would not
significantly significantly affect the
character of the park and would have
wider community and benefits it's
acknowledged that some Works including
the creation of a new qriket pitch and
improvements to the tennis course and
the pump track would likely increase
visitors to the park in usage of the
park bringing formal uses to currently
informal open areas nevertheless
the use is wholly appropriate to the
character of the site as a public park
and giving the existing relationship
with neighboring Residential Properties
separate and separation distances the
impact is not considered significant
additional lighting would increase
safety to routes through the park and
would be controlled by planning
condition to ensure there's no undougal
air to Residents free light spillage or
glare
there would be a reduction in car
parking throughout the site as we seek
to encourage active travel but there
will be an increase in disabled parking
spaces
this is um part of implant improvements
to pedestrian routes throughout the park
and also improving wayfinding throughout
the park and also creation of a new
formal access from Rye Bank Road
there will be improvements to existing
facilities with new toilets including
accessible toilets within the Long Barn
as well as refurbishment of the existing
toilet Block in the world Garden however
further detail is required I'll set out
in condition 30. in addition the site
already has toilet provision including a
changing places toilet within the cafe
which is also accessible from outside
the cafe and there are also improvements
to site accessibility with resurfacing
work to improve the quality of footpaths
throughout the park the carpeting of
Longford Brook and habitat creation
an improvement work suit to enhance
biodiversity and Wildlife across the
site and now set out in the air the
environment agency have now withdrawn
their objection to the scheme
it is acknowledged that the pump track
is is an area of concern for residents
and detailed conditions seek to address
these concerns with full details
necessary to be provided prior to any
works expensing on the pump track
however given the distance between the
pump track and residents the location is
considered acceptable in principle
this application presents an opportunity
for the council to achieve funding for
much-needed Improvement rights to the
park the proposals have been considered
against the mppf and the council's
course strategy and it's considered the
benefits of granting Parliament
permission outweigh any Harms in doing
so and therefore approval is recommended
I'd also just like to inform counselors
that a number of The Works proposed in
fact a substantial amount of the
workplace would be covered by the
council's permitted development however
because of the variety of work proposed
and uncertainty over some of the details
and in regards to transparency a
planning application has been submitted
in full thank you
thank you Miss Miller
um Miss Murder
yeah so if you just make sure the
microphone is on in front of you thank
you and you'll have three minutes to
speak to us so we'll start the timer
once you start speaking okay thank you
I'd just say given the amount of detail
that three minutes is certainly not
enough
um points to cover
um Longford Park is the conservation
area is protected open space and a
wildlife Corridor there must be
preservation of the natural environment
and Wildlife any development must be
replaced or replaced with light for like
um natural habitat this includes any
proposed parking area extensions the
pump track the position of this trap
means that residents in close proximity
will have a significant increase in
noise nuisance potential lack of privacy
given the height of the structure and
loss of visual amenity plus harm to the
character of the park residents backing
onto the park already have to deal with
antisocial Behavior at night and around
the Adventure Playground construction
materials in the conservation area are
most delightful like if the product
track meets conservation standards the
positioning is very poorly thought out
this encourages trafficking Cromwell
Road entrance and additional traffic
through the narrow space access passive
playground and Cafe this is already a
dangerous and highly pedestrianized area
so encourages more cars into an area
which is very irresponsible it's also
very important we have very limited
access for ambulance services it's
highly restricted there is a risk of
bikers riding through the brook and over
to the adventure player areas where
smaller children are in danger of being
knocked over there's also a serious
issue with dangerous dirt bikers on this
side of the park and this encourages
more of anti-social Behavior there is
better access on the Eastern side of the
park for the pump track and it is more
direct from Longford Road near the
stadium and more parking facilities on
that side of the park
it is
um more dedicated to sports facilities
and there are more importantly no local
residents backing onto that area of the
park
the open Brook this is a concern to
local residents who will now need to
declare their properties are at flooding
risk to an open Waterway to insurance
companies the residents need assurance
that the volume of water can be
controlled using these methods given the
capacity to drain into the Culvert has
been exceeded in recent years and it
seems that the surveys have
underestimated the flood risks in the
reports the budget for maintenance on
this Waterway is vital
as it may require frequent dissilting
and removal of litter blockages Open
Water means there is a potential risk of
drowning particularly in such close
proximity to children's play areas and
this needs to be safety measures in
place the aims to improve biodiversity
May negatively be affected by the
presence of a pump trap right next to it
the Japanese Gardens the plans for this
area are at travesty to remove all
vegetation from this area and fill it
with gravel is completely incompatible
with the conservation of wildlife
habitat and natural spaces this is
modern design interpretation in an
affront to the park Aesthetics there are
several other issues within the design
appearance of the park outline and some
of the planning objections that should
be accounted for including the
demarcation of green spaces overall
there's a lack of amenities in the
design including toilets bins seating
and calves area there would have to be
Assurance of significant budget increase
of Maintenance to additional facilities
currently there's no budget to maintain
the facilities within the park presently
easy to spend a bulk amount but
budgeting for proper maintenance takes
real management and this is seriously
lacking at the moment long-term
maintenance it's going to be required
and defined budget where is the money
coming from and how long will it last to
maintain the park it's not a one-off
okay thank you if you'd like to return
to your seat at the back please is um
Graham Addison with us you'd like to
come up to the seat opposite me thank
you
so thank you Mr Elton you'll have three
minutes to speak to us once you start
talking thank you okay evening thanks
Jack and committee so just want to use
this time to outline the the benefits of
the application
um clearly Longford parks are well loved
well used Park a really strong community
and volunteer involvement uh friends
group pets Corner the community
allotment group disc golf the scouts all
operating there within the park he's
also got the cafe and popular events
such as the the park run we've listened
carefully to all those all those groups
as well as individuals in the public
consultation that's uh for help
formulate the the plans in front of you
um in terms of the benefits
um we're looking to address the defects
within the park with restoration of
historic features the war Garden haha
the remaining elements of the the Hall
of portico
drainage is a basic issue as a lot of
people know within the park water
logging and flooded footpaths are
commonplace so key to this is opening up
Longford Brook and we're linking this to
The Wider wider landscape we have done a
for hydrology assessment within the Buns
um so we're very confident in terms of
the how that works
um Long Barn we're restoring the
building bringing into positive public
use as a hub for the community and
volunteering groups
in terms of sport and play we have
improvements to both play areas new
equipment and surfacing creating a BMX
from pump track as we've heard they've
got majority support for that in the in
the public consultation it should be
said
we're making space for qriket pitch with
an artificial Wicket resurfacing the
fence and fencing the the tennis courts
and the multi-use games area there's
improvements to disc golf as well
reconfiguring Pet's Corner says improved
facilities for animals and the
volunteers we're addressing the traffic
issues so when they design and access
payment it clearly sets out a number of
actions to reduce the number of vehicles
moving through the park where they
remain how they will be segregated from
pedestrian use where possible
accessibility is a key driver
um with new footpaths from Edge Lane
Cromwell Avenue and Rye Bank Road
resurfacing of others
um we hope to provide users with a
greater understanding of the heritage of
the park for the interpretation
proposals that includes a permanent
exhibition within Long Barn and also the
internal footprint of the the hall will
be modified to set out the rooms as it
was as it was intended and used uh we're
improving the lighting which is uh for
the use safety of users we're creating
more welcoming entrances The Parks
befitting of the conservation area and
making improvements to biodiversity
Nutri planting areas of meadow Wetland
areas so in summary the implementation
of these proposals I would suggest
leaves the park in a better condition
more accessible the greater range of
facilities to meet the wide wide range
in needs of the community
finally planning permission unlocks the
next phase of the uh the funding
application so we're looking for a 3.2
million pound Grant from the national
lottery that also includes a management
and maintenance plan funding as well to
address some concerns raised earlier
to speak for the proposal so um you'll
have up to five minutes
um we'll start the timer when you
start to speak thank you okay thank you
chair I don't intend to use uh four or
five minutes
um yeah I'd just like to welcome the
application
um The Heritage Lottery fund bid has
been been a long process which is a
result of a lot of hard work by officers
staff volunteers and Friends of Longford
Park
this is a one-off opportunity for
funding from the Heritage Lottery fund
for what is widely regarded as one of
the best parks in Trafford
Longford park is in a compass
conversation sorry Conservation Area and
the recent public consultation
identified improvements which they they
wanted to see
for example in new facilities the the
BMX pump track
sports facilities such as a cricket
pitch as well as a new infrastructure
including paths and gateways
um refurbishment of existing facilities
such as the Long Barn for volunteering
activities
the car Parks pets Corner tennis courts
the Longford Hall footprint and Portico
which is all uh going to be enhanced to
emphasize the heritage of the hall in
the gardens
environmental improvements
um including the opening of Longford
Brook and The Works to address the
flooding serious flooding issues we've
seen there
in the past
the promotion of active travel and the
reduction of car use
um the recommendation is to Grant so
what I hope you're going to approve is
is improvements to almost every aspect
of the park
whilst Eric set there is opposition to
certain uh to certain aspects of it and
some of it well grounded
I will it will be a fantastic overall
benefit for the community thank you
thank you against the German
um members of the committee looking
today I'll come to the Council of
prompter first thank you
this is amazing it's such a brilliant
opportunity for Longford Park
um I propose we accept this
thank you cancel the Proctor councilor
Thomas
thank you chair I wholeheartedly agree
uh parks in the area have for a long
time now not had the allocation of cash
for one reason or another to keep them
um
viable uh Parks need to but certainly
like Longford Park
uh need to attract ages from
toddler to oap
that have interests within the park the
pump track I used to many years ago
before I became unfit I used to do cycle
Speedway and you know until I had to go
at tyldesley for it because that's the
only place you could do it and young and
old alike
use that facility fantastically this is
the next stage forward of making sure
that Longford Park stays as a park
within the community servicing all
aspects of the community it is a park
already there are parking issues there
we know but they are there as we speak
and isn't really a planning
consideration on this particular
proposal
the only thing the only downside I've
only found now tonight is that the
cricket pitch is an artificial Wicket uh
we have lost too many grass wickets are
open to public but it's something that's
not there before so there's a cricket
piece there I wholeheartedly support it
and I'm happy to Second Council
Proctor's uh proposal to agree
thank you councilor Thomas cancel a
minute
um I'm just just glad to see you before
we've rounded up managed to get um some
Lottery film to money to regenerate
um a park I think this is wonderful I
think got suitable things there for all
ages
um and that's great because actually it
gives when when we have mention of
anti-social Behavior actually gives
people things to do that's what you want
you want um children of all ages to have
things to do rather than you know being
bored and having nothing to do they
don't want to be cooled up in their
houses they want to be able to go out
with their friends and do something fun
and so absolutely yes in favor thank you
thank you councilor win Stanley
here tonight I think
um I'm really thrilled with the plans uh
particularly around the Landscaping
improving the Heritage areas around the
range of the hall the uncle and
something uncoverting of the brook which
will solve
um the flooding issues and also provide
a feature in the park uh there's just
too many things I can praise in this I
understand the concerns of the neighbors
I do as perhaps councilor Thomas has
already pointed out there are already
issues of anti-social behavior that
there's already issues around parking I
think those things tend to go with Parks
wherever those parks are some of the
issues have been addressed with the um
with the the uh the traffic reduction
plans as part of this overall so yeah
I'm really happy to support this thank
you chair
thank you cancer akinola
um just a quick question
um my assumption is that um friends
along for the park
um are fully support in this bed
yes they do support it thank you
thank you counselor Hassan right thank
you very much
I've been living this world and this uh
only two minutes were up in 20 years
and uh I've been a
Peter and advocate for north of Barrow
which has been ignored and I'm I will
say that we are very lucky enough it's
not all about the park it is going to
become a holistic Park which will cover
the mental and social and sports and
cultural values of the north and
generations to come
and I've been involved these groups
Community groups and it was desperately
needed uh such an innovation in the
north of the borough and and and and
then this will cover
uh everything the sports and and indeed
Cricut page and uh sunny or and also
there is a Bowling Green a football
pitches and tennis and basketballs and a
cafe and and uh
the honorability has mentioned about the
social antisocial Behavior anti-social
behavior is in the right in the front of
the Downey Street as well so it is
everywhere so and and I think and it
will cover uh the speaker has just
mentioned who has spoken in the favor of
this uh about the ecology assessment has
already been done and and then it's a
water logging so it is uh one of the
most beautiful addition will be in the
north the borough and I will fully
support this application and recommend
the application of the of a
recommendation of the officers thank you
thank you Council Hassan any of the
members looking to speak
for my part I I'm enthusiastic about the
application I think it's a really good
opportunity to
um to renovate a lot of features in in
longer part which is a brilliant Park
but it is looking a bit tired in places
and
um actually agree with councilor Minis
that you know the partner near to me is
is is doesn't have anywhere near the
sort of facilities that Longford Park do
but you regularly get you know teenagers
getting on the roof of the bowling
Pavilion and stuff and you know I've
told them to get down and I've asked
them why they do it and it's because
they're bored but this park has got it
already has a very diverse range of
facilities and and that will improve uh
more so with this work
um I understand the concerns of
residence but I do think
it's a difficult application because a
lot of the detail is vague because I
know this has been put together really
quickly and you know I'd like to commend
the people involved in in the bid for
the funding and also planning offices
for helping to put together this this
application so quickly
um some of the plans are vague but I
think that you know the risk around
those is mitigated by the very long set
of conditions that we've got uh
including regarding the pump track which
I know is a concern but
I can't imagine that a pump track design
will be approved that you know consists
of lots of concrete banking or whatever
it's going to be a a naturally landscape
pump track that is likely to be
acceptable there
um councilor Thomas did you want to come
back in yeah specifically on the pump
track uh
um one of the in the air the one of the
objects were that the demographic will
be boys aged 18 8 to 18 uh to the pump
track Holly disagree with that only in
2021 in Tokyo best three were won our
first ever gold medal for BMX she's a
female
okay they will attract people that want
to use the sport and if the facilities
are good enough those will have
ownership of that facility and ensure
that he's kept in the right order and in
the right sort of manner
foreign Thomas it's uh yeah it's quite
well made I agree um so I think it's
been moving seconded that we um we're
Grant planning permission as per the
recommendation so we'll vote on that
motion now please all those in
uh no we can't engage in debate with
with them with with people watching so
we're going to move to the vote now so
um all of those in favor of granting
upon and permission if you indicate now
please
so that's uh it's unanimous so that
application is approved thank you I'm
going to recommend we take a five minute
Comfort break but if we say five minutes
please just so we can apply one thank
you
okay thank you everybody uh we'll resume
now with um uh
application108808 which is one five
seven hail Road in hell so thank you for
your patience everybody this is at page
20 of the bundle for members
um we will start with an introduction
from Miss Coley thank you
thank you chair
um
the application site is on the corner of
Hale Road and gray Sands Road within a
residential area of hail the plot
currently comprises a large detached
Bungalow built around the 1930s with a
separate attached garage to the east of
the dwelling access from Hale Road
The Proposal is for the demolition of
the Bungalow and outbuildings and
replacement with two four bedroom
semi-detached dwellings and Associated
Landscaping the dwellings would be
three-story which includes the
accommodation within the roof space in
addition there would be accommodation at
basement level
the frontage of the dwellings would be
set slightly further forward to the
properties to the west and slightly
further back from the dwellings to the
east on the opposite side of graceland's
road in line with the staggered building
line along Hale Road
the existing access points to the site
would be retained with slight
alterations the dwelling on the West
Side plot one would use the access from
Hale Road and the dwelling on the east
side plot 2 would use the existing
access point from Gray Sands Road
those properties will have a private
immunity space the West Side property
would have the majority of its Garden
space to the rear and the property on
the east side would have private
immunity space to the sides in front
the proposed development will provide
one net additional dwelling following
the demolition of the existing property
all detail batters have been assessed
including the principle of the proposed
development its appearance scale layout
access and parking and impacts on labor
immunity
or relevant planning issues are being
considered and representation and
consultation responses taken into
account
the issues are found to be acceptable
with where appropriate specific
mitigation is secured by planning
condition
in terms of mppf paragraph 11d2 the
Tilted balance there are no adverse
impacts that were significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
granting planning permission
which is therefore concluded the
application should be approved subject
to appropriate conditions thank you
thank you is Abigail Wilson with us
come and have a seat opposite uh me Miss
Wilson so you'll have three minutes to
speak to us just make sure the
microphones on if you just press the
button on the base that's it is that
yeah no we can hear you now so you'll
have three minutes from when you start
talking thank you
and thank you for this opportunity to
speak
as a resident of one gray Sands Road I
oppose the scale of this development and
would like to highlight my concerns and
the objections from 13 other local
residents
the application site as we've heard is a
sloping Corner plot and this exaggerates
the impact of height and density of
buildings massing separation distances
and resulting loss of immunity
trafford's policy says infield
development shouldn't be at the expense
of the immunity of surrounding
properties and here even the planners
seem to treat the proposal as at the
very limit of what may be acceptable
this stipulate as many as 18 conditions
including a key one pivoting any further
development without permission
the application describes two-story
housing but page two of the planning
report clearly states the dwellings
would be three-story
with accommodation proposed over four
levels including within the roof we
strongly agree the proposed houses
should be treated as three stories the
Steep roof and flat fronted roof Gables
strengthen this impression together with
Windows in roof Gables at the front
the planners rely on policy pg-1 to
identify relevant separation distances
for three-story houses like these on a
level site it recommends at least 13 and
a half meters separation to the boundary
at ground floor level
these houses would only be ten and a
half meters from our boundary and only
12.6 meters at first floor so we suggest
the policy is not met
also the size slopes dropping over half
a meter from the proposed ground floor
level down to our boundary so again we
suggest greater separation is required
even if the houses are treated as
two-story and as such it's said the
minimum separation distances of ten and
a half meters is met we respectfully
disagree we say the separation needs to
be greater because of the slope
positioned so close the houses would be
totally dominating overbearing and
oppressive especially when we're in the
garden with a dense wall of development
along most of our side boundary causing
considerable loss of immunity
there'd be clear views from the bedroom
windows leaving no part of our garden
private anymore and our Landing window
will look straight into new bedroom
windows
the new roof Ridge Heights would be two
and a half meters higher than our house
and if you add another half meter to
this to reflect the slope the houses
will appear immense from our garden
We Believe replacing the existing
Bungalow with three-story houses would
cause loss of sunlight in our Gardens
and increase shady areas already
resulting from the development taken
place previously at 155 Hale Road
The Proposal would increase traffic and
parking on the road at an already
difficult Junction
in summary the net benefit of increasing
trafford's housing stock by just one
four bedroom semi is far outweighed we
suggest by the adverse impact on the
local environment and residence loss of
immunity and we respectfully suggest
this application is therefore not
appropriate for approval
thank you thank you very much thank you
for coming to speak to us
um
councilor young thank you for your
patience you'll have up to five minutes
to speak to us so we'll start the clock
once you start speaking thank you
okay thank you can I do it from here
well thank you for letting me speak this
planning application seeks to replace
one single story Bungalow with two large
and luxurious four-bedroomed houses each
containing
four bathrooms two studies two medium
games room then laundry utility and two
cloak rooms in addition to all the other
standard rooms kitchen Diner Etc that
one would expect to find in an average
four bedroomed house
replacing the hail Road Bungalow with
these two three-story properties will be
too dense suppressive and overbearing
neighboring properties on hail Road have
larger plots
and frontages young families who live in
4A and 6A graysons Road will lose the
sunlight and enjoyment of their front
Gardens this being their only Garden
space within the sunlight
as a corner plot the impact on Grayson's
Road of all features must not be treated
as of secondary importance to that on
Hill Road but the proposed properties
are really only considered in relation
to the housing to the houses to the West
on hail Road the character and
appearance of the houses is very
different on Grayson's Road
the planning report says that the height
scale and design of The Proposal is very
similar to 155 Hale Road so if it's a
street scene but on site the plan is
accepted but 155 Hale Road does not
represent a shining example of good
planning
at the committed hearing for 155 hail
ale Road members have expressed surprise
that the original permission had ever
been granted
the difference in Ridge levels between
the proposed properties and gray Sands
road is significant the new properties
would have a steeple roof than the
existing Bungalow would be of
considerable scale and massing with a
ridge level 2.5 meters higher than the
Bungalow
the planning report says the new Ridge
height will be one meter lower than 155
hail road but it will be 2.5 meters
higher than one Grayson's Road
this will not enhance all sit well in
the street scene of Grayson's Road
the sloping sights on the change in
levels between the houses and the garden
of one Grayson's road which is over half
a meter will increase the perception of
excessive Heights especially from the
rear Garden
the adverse impacts on the street scene
and the Wilson's amenity is not
adequately addressed by the six meters
set back from The Bungalow position
referred to in the planning report
the proposed mass of the new buildings
adjacent to 155 hail road with a stick
out and dominate the street scene to an
unacceptable degree and will Overlook
neighbors causing loss of light and
privacy
there will be no area in the garden of
number one gray Sands road which will
not be overlooked by 155 hail Road or by
the the propels new development
the sloping site on the change in levels
between the houses and the garden of one
gray Sands which exceeds half a meter
will increase the perception of excess
of excessive Heights
the atlas impacts of the proposed
three-story development cannot be
mitigated by Landscaping The Proposal
would simply combine the adverse impact
already arising from the 155 hail road
development
the properties would be overly
dominating in the street scene and
cannot be screened by Landscaping
there will also be a significant loss of
green space and hail needs to preserve
every single remaining spot of green
that it still has
I appreciate that this development would
add another house to the number of
houses that we are expected to provide
in Trafford but I do question whether it
is necessary to allow a development on
quite the scale as I said earlier these
are not just houses but Top Class luxury
dwellings and it should be more than
possible to build two acceptable
four-bedroom semis on a smaller scale
that would not be so overbearingly
dominant in the street scene and to the
neighbors thank you
thank you counselor young as uh Jonathan
riddle here please if you'd like to come
and have a seat opposite me
um
I think that microphone is already on so
just make sure you're close to the
microphone hello is it on yeah yeah and
you'll have um three minutes to speak to
us when you once you start talking we'll
start the clock thank you um
it's been a while since I was here
actually
anyway
um I'm Jonathan riddle from art design
Services director of art design services
and the client would like to have been
here this evening but he couldn't make
it because he's looking after his wife
who's got dementia unfortunately
um
the client has lived in the property
since 1987.
it was a family home for when he grew up
when his children grew up and they've
obviously obviously subsequently left
home and moved abroad
the proposals are for
a two separate 70 tax dwellings for him
and his wife and his son who's coming
back from abroad to live in this
property to help look after his wife
the design has been well thought out and
fully considered in relation to size
height design integrity
a neighborhood impact Street Scene and
also the new emerging Trafford design
codes
we've taken onboard comments that were
made before Christmas
work very closely with the planning team
team leaders
met them on site to discuss amendments
to the proposals
and
we've we've made significant changes to
the the size of the dwellings the height
of the dwellings the positioning
and
a footprint and improved elements on the
Landscaping as well
we've also produced several visuals
which I think you've probably seen
hopefully to assist to sort of help
visualize the street scene elevations
which is something that we talked about
after Christmas to try and help you sort
of Judge the properties
um and as far as we were since we made
all the amendments to this game
I don't believe there's been any further
objections other than what we've heard
tonight
so
I just wanted to say that um
the last point is that it is for a
family and
we've worked with the Council on many
many schemes for the last 20 years
and providing similar sorts of schemes
to to provide family dwellings and we
urge the community members to support
the planning recommendation for approval
and approve the screen to enable the
family and members to see out their days
in hail basically thank you very much
thank you for coming to speak to us Mr
riddle um
I'll uh just looking at indications of
people who want to speak I'm just going
to ask Miss curly for some advice on
something that
um as Wilson mentioned when she spoke to
us which was about the separation
distances and uh I think her point was
that in reality these are three-story
houses so the separation distances
um should be greater so I want to give
us some advice on that thank you yes uh
no problem chairman I could I could
explain uh the separation distances that
are mentioned in the report
um are those for two-story dwellings but
that's because they are privacy
distances rather than distances to avoid
any kind of overbearing impact
um that so and because there are only
windows in the rear elevation that faces
unturnable on Grace and road at ground
and first floor in privacy terms it is a
two-story dwelling there are only roof
lights in the roof so they would they
look up rather than across
um therefore the the distances that are
set out in the officer report are the
correct ones in these circumstances and
they either meet or exceed the distances
that are required thank you
thank you very much
um against the minute she wanted to
speak thank you
I was just indulging myself with a
Google Earth and Google Maps now the
thing is it shows Google Maps is still
it was the old building next door at
155.
um and uh Google Earth has obviously
been updated with the new building I
think that's that's I know that's not
that is not the application here but I
think that to match something like that
would actually be a poor a poor idea uh
for this plot
um and I mean I don't know how the hell
the thing next door got um got allowed
but that's a different matter
um I think that quite frankly the size
massing loss of immunity to number one I
think it's unacceptable
um and I'll be proposing that we refuse
um this application based on size scale
massing height it is going to be
overbearing awesome amenity to the
neighbor at number one I think it's
unacceptable
um and that's my that's my proposal
thank you
thank you chair
um I broadly like it the the move
forward of the of the property does give
the distance
155 generally is the is the property
that would Overlook the rear Garden of
number one uh although I am sympathetic
with the uh resident number one I don't
think it's enough to uh possibly
um gun refusal there's no grounds for it
there's two properties coming out with
the parking is exemplary uh there's
enough room for three cars to each
property without any disturbance to uh
the roadways in in inside and I'm happy
to propose that we agree with the
officer's recommendation I do have one
query in the conditions it says that the
avoid delivery is Monday to Friday
between 10 and four
which seem to avoid school hours that
seems to be perhaps only within ten to
four rather than
outside of them I think that's a
drafting error thank you for appointing
it I just wanted to double check because
I'd suggest perhaps ten to three is a
better time but I'm happy to propose
that we accept
well spotted councilor tell us we know
you're doing preparation
um counselor
uh thanks Joe
um uh so I remember this when uh it came
when the planning list came out before
Christmas and I remember looking at it
thinking
this is pretty big and monolithful I'm
not monolithic but it is um it's a
pretty big development and probably
unsuitable um
uh I do quite like the design
um of it as there's a lot of thought
going into it and I will
um acknowledge the work that officers
and the applicant have done to to
mitigate a lot of the problems
um
but I still I'm still of the opinion
it's it's too big and it's it's gonna
it's overbearing it's going to
overshadow number one uh Grayson's um if
you stand at the bottom of of uh
Grayson's Road looking up
it well look it will spoil the scene
from that direction in my opinion I
think there's probably a bit more work
to be done um but I'm happy to Second
well I'd like to Second the council
Minister's proposal uh to refuser based
on my sink and scale
thank you uh councilor Morgan
thanks chair um do you honest I haven't
decided yet how I'm going to vote on
this um I'm interested to just hear more
people um totally get by the doing what
they they want they're proposing it's
effective replica
give or take of next door
um
does actually fit seen in in the north
side of Hill Road at that part of hail
Road it tends to be
um on the South Side it tends to be a
bit lower
um
um and so this Bongo kind of has stood
out up to that point
um but it is a big massive building in
comparison to certainly to the to the
north of it
um and there is the difference in in in
in height because of the drop in the
Hill from Hale Road
um
um there's a thing when you represent
hail or hail bonds there is actually
Hills in Trafford
um and um
I mean and it is directly to the south
of its neighbors so it will really
impact in terms of the light
um when it the sun is in
um is outside of the peak of the summer
so I'm just not really sure
um I think I think I think there is an
element of
of massing
um
I'm just not sure if it's enough to
reject it
um so sorry I'm just kind of download my
thoughts but um thank you
Proctor
thank you chair
I'd like to Second counselor Thomas's
motion to accept this
I had two concerns
um one of which
I'm not concerned about anymore when I
looked at it I didn't realize there
weren't any Windows facing number one
so they're not going to be overlooked
they'll have a
but yeah not on the top yeah on the
ground floor first floor so they're not
going to be overlooked massively by this
house my other concern which can be
addressed by
um
conditions it doesn't comply with part m
on accessibility
that's the only thing it doesn't comply
with it's got ground floor shower rooms
um
if there could be a condition attached
to that
to say they have to have step free
access that would be wonderful thank you
I think there is Council Proctor just
bear with me I'm trying to find which
one it is
0.62
foreign
of the officer's report
condition three Council Proctor
says there should be a condition
um it's not in the air is it
I'm sure I will be reading it
yeah but if you're trying to find the
conditions
yeah it's in condition three Council
property
thank you um if you have any more
comments kind of support you
you done yeah no that's okay uh cancer
akinola I've got nothing further to say
now Shirley just covered the points I
was gonna second
and I was also really pleased that um
this build actually has got is future
proofed and I really like that
thank you um councilor Winston brief
I'll be voted in favor of this uh to
return to councilor Morgan's points
about being unsure about the matching I
don't think it is over massinger
overbearing
um and also we need to give some credit
to the developer for working with our uh
with our planning team to get to change
the plans in line with uh those that we
requested so I will be building in favor
of this thank you chip
thank you Ken counselor Wilson
thank you yes I mean I've been going
through a similar uh um uh process to
councilor Morgan on this I do understand
that it's um it's uh on the on the slope
that does make a does make a difference
it is tall
um but it is moving back on the plot
um and I so what I have in my head is
the uh is
the Tilted balance but and I know we
have to take that into consideration
um I don't think the um the impact on
residential immunity is sufficient to
overcome that tilted balance so I will
be voting in favor of them
um proposal thank you
thank you councilor uh Welton I was um
going to say something very similar so I
won't repeat it and you know I recognize
for the neighbor it's it's different to
what's there so the massing will be
different
um it'll be set further back but it will
be taller
um and for my own part I'm not sure that
um that is sufficient to to refuse
planning permission
um
so it has been it's been moved and
seconded that we refuse uh permission
and
the reasons I heard from uh counselor
chalkin were around
um
overbearing nature and massing is that
sufficient sorry catch the minute scale
of massing yeah
um
in terms of straight saying sorry my
usual reminder the scale and massing
isn't itself a harm and you have to
identify the harm but I've heard from
council's chalkin that that was to the
street scene you've got seen on on
um
okay so that uh that's that exhibition
so we'll vote first on the
um on the motion to uh refuse so all
those in favor of refusal if you could
indicate now please
do you guys think
if you're in favor of refusal please
okay and against refusal please
nine okay
okay so that that motion is uh is not
carried
so we'll vote now on the motion that's
been moved and seconded to Grant
planning permission so well I was in
favor of granting permission please
Kenny and all those against Grant a
permission please
so that application is granted so thank
you very much for your time and thank
you to our speakers
uh move on we'll move on now to
um
uh application one one zero one one nine
which is 26 Hermiston Lane in Stratford
starts on page 189 of the bundle cancel
the win Stanley's leaving us for this
item as as indicated at the start and
we'll start with um
an introduction from Ms Milner thank you
thank you chair so this application site
relates to a two-story property
um at basement and ground floor is
currently a dentist and they're in the
first floor and second floor are two two
bed Flats
The Proposal is to extend the dental
practice into the first and second floor
removing the existing residential use
and creating a additional two
consultancy rooms providing a total of
four
external alterations are limited to a
new platform lift to the front of the
property given the changing levels and
alterations to the bin storage
whilst inside the property there's no
uplift access it is considered that the
Improvement to the access into the
building is on balance acceptable
the site has
um no off-street parking and does
provide
um so there's no opportunity parking
existing or proposed with the with the
site
however offices have looked at the site
and whilst we do accept that parking
demand in the area is high it is
considered to be in a highly sustainable
location it is very close to Stratford
town center and is in close proximity to
Stratford Mall and the parking provided
there it's also
very close to existing bus routes and a
10 minute walk to Stratford Metrolink
offices are satisfied that the impact
from the existing use to the proposed
use would not result in a severe impact
on the highway and free parking demand
and therefore do not see this as a
reason for refusal
in regards to the impact on amenity
the Cummins can go into the site are not
considered to be so great as to cause
harm to the amenity of the adjacent
Residential Properties
And in regards to the noise of the use
this is considered acceptable given the
hours of use proposed and outlined in
your conditions
therefore subject to the conditions
outlined within your report we do
recommend approval thank you
thank you is Mr Stiles with us
thank you for your patience Mr Styles
just have a seat opposite me I think the
microphone is on so just make sure
you're close to it and you'll have three
minutes to speak to us and we'll start
clock once you start speaking thank you
okay thank you
um I'll just depart from my script just
to say a bit about how unsustainable
this location is the proximity of a bus
stop doesn't make it sustainable the
it's the frequency of the services that
counts and that many of them are
infrequent
uh 10 minutes walk to the metro station
is a joke uh it takes uh that long to
cross the Chester Road sometimes
um
if it was a sustainable location we
wouldn't have the parking problem that
has arisen since this dentist practice
uh opened
this proposal is an intensification of
an existing use that has no off-street
parking spaces and inadequate disabled
access the situation is the reason
because the planning department failed
to ensure there was the requisite 16
parking spaces with the original
planning consent
this is not a highly sustainable
location as the report suggests where
parking standards can be relaxed the
report acknowledges that the site is on
a trunk road across a busy Junction from
the Town Center making pedestrian access
difficult the nearest metro station is
across two busy Junctions and 800 meters
away for most users of this private
dental practice the only realistic
option for most parts of the borough
will be driving
we consider policy L4 should carry some
way due to the site not being a
sustainable location the existing
inadequate parking provision and given
the level of local opposition
summarizing the representations title at
the beginning of the report
the report States the expanded dental
practice will require three disabled
spaces yet currently there is only one
on Street disabled Bay that is not
exclusive to the practice the local
hardware Authority has not raised an
objection on this basis they consider
such an objection could not be sustained
at appeal however combined with the
unsustainable location and current
inadequate parking residents consider
there is a strong case refusal on
inadequate disabled access country to
the office's conclusions
the absence of off-street dedicated
disabled parking does limit
accessibility of the premises for some
patients and is contrary to guidance in
core strategy policy L 7.5 and ppf and
the provisions of the equality Act 2010.
this is not a sustainable location or an
accessible site therefore these are
material considerations and there should
be no nppf presumption in favor of this
proposed development current parking
problems in the area are a direct result
of the inadequate provision in early
planning approvals if this proposal is
permitted the intensified use of the
site will exacerbate the parking
problems that already impacts negatively
on the amenity of local residents
thank you
thank you very much and is uh jabir
Diwali with us um
Mr Dodge come and have a seat opposite
uh me and um
you know speaking in favor of the
application so you'll have um three
minutes to speak to us once you start
speaking thank you
um perfect um thank you very much for
letting me speak this evening
um I'm going to be honest I actually
agree with Mr Styles he does raise some
valid points there's no two ways about
it on that street parking is an issue
and I get that and in all honesty
I don't know how to fix that issue per
se and residents have every right to
look to their elected representatives to
try and represent their interest I think
the only thing that I'd like to do this
evening is just to provide a little bit
of context to the parking issue right
next door to our dental practice there
is an aid surgery practice that will see
20 to 30 patients per surgery every
single day and we have two surgeries
they are rarely ever in use
simultaneously and we'll see between 10
to 15 patients today parking is
definitely an issue I I don't disagree
and I don't necessarily know how to fix
that issue
um that's that's for you guys to decide
I'm a dentist by trade
I know what the loading time of
amoxicillin is and what tertiary dentine
means but the parking issue I can't it
isn't one that I can necessarily uh help
to try and fix we in relation to
disabled access as part of us being able
to open that dental practice and we
underwent aacqc inspection and we have
got wheelchair access and for that for
for our dental practice and I'm not
trying to throw anybody under the bus
the practice next door does not and
they've had their CQC approval way
before the CQC was even I think and I
want to also say with Rio Dental it is a
private dental practice it's by way of
Google review metrics the third highest
rated practice in Manchester
and we're really proud of the service
that we provide of course massage is
right it is a private practice having
said that roughly this time last week we
saw Julia's daughter was nine years old
and because Aaron and his dentist
couldn't see her nobody would help her
and then we did that pro bono and we we
don't advertise the fact that we do that
because it isn't sustainable but we do
try and give back we we we think we're a
positive influence to the local
community we employ I think just as I
was coming in I saw I kept Academy 92 I
think it's called and Somerset one of
our staff members is a student there we
employ people locally and I think we're
a benefit to to essentially being there
so whatever decision you guys reached
this evening will will be more than
satisfied with uh but I just want you to
have a think about it in context on
Barton Road as soon as you turn left
you've got 10 businesses not a single
one of them has allocated parking spaces
and more times no we've actually bought
the brunt of parking issues even when
the surgery hasn't been in use we're
lucky we have CCTV camera there's
photographic evidence of our staff being
harassed by people saying well
somebody's parked in my space when we
haven't and the message from us has
always been the same these that they are
our neighbors and to treat them without
the most respect and we've never said
anything in relation to that and I thank
you guys for yourself
thank you very much Mr Darley for coming
to speak to us
um
I think I'll just ask um Miss Miller for
some advice on the
the previous application
um this is addressed in the air and O so
there was a previous planning
application to convert the
the current premises into a dental
practice but that wasn't implemented so
in fact the change was I think permitted
development and I think that might have
an impact here on
um at the point that Mr Stiles raised
about why didn't we insist on 16 parking
spaces at that stage thank you
so the planning permission and related
to 24 and 26
and that was from 2020.
in 2021 the government changed the use
class order
and it meant that the previous use of a
hairdresser and also being a shop
previously Class A
yes it'd be no it interchanged and that
would be in class A and it was going to
a d use but then in 2021 they both moved
into the same use classy
so the planning permission we've looked
at that and we don't think it was
implemented because there were a number
of discrepancies between what we
approved and what's currently going on
site therefore it is
completely reasonable for officers to
conclude that this use is lawful because
it it wasn't a change in in youth class
and therefore it could be carried out
under permitted development so the
existing surgery
the change views to the dental surgery
took place under permitted development
and therefore no parking was required so
they have two consultancy rooms
currently and I would draw your
attention to the fact that we have
restricted further changes of use within
classy
um classy is now um quite an extensive
um coverage of different news classes
and to stop further kind of changes that
are unrestricted we have sought to to
restrict that we've also in that same
condition restricted the number of
consultancy rooms
um at this unit to a maximum of full
thank you thank you very much members
looking to speak on this item cancer
racingella
I welcome the change in um that there's
going to be disabled access into the
building even though there isn't any
disabled parking and um
parking has always been an issue around
that neck of the woods
um for those who can get across the
world like say there is stretford mall
where you can park
um for free for a couple of hours
um
I can't see all the objections seem to
be about traffic and um
and that's not something we've got
control of so I personally would be
proposing that we go with the officers
recommendation and agree
thank you Council I can always cancel
Hassan
so I secondly to my colleague
parking is a it's a national issue and
uh
and officer has just
given the strong
in regards to parking and we are getting
complaints every single day is working
and and we desperately need dentists to
be honest in that area and particularly
in the north of at the Barrow and people
every single day are struggling to go to
the dentist number one and there are
many parking places available in behind
the streets I know this area very well
and and there are bus connections there
is this road is have a lot of
connectivity in regards to the the bus
and the Tron and of course and uh draft
wood console uh now trying to enhance
more and more seconding routes and the
walking rules throughout the Trafford a
barrel so I don't think there is any
problem not to give this grant this
application I fully support the
officer's recommendation and a second to
my colleague thank you
thank you cancer Thomas thank you if
this this will run to the dentist go
away would it would it ease in any way
shape or form any of the parking issues
suffered by residents no it wouldn't as
a brown shop that probably had one
customer a day the parking issues were
there it isn't residential parking it is
on road parking nobody as well unless
there's a residence scheme has a
specific right to park outside the house
most of us would like to and back in the
day when I was a younger we all could
because there was nowhere near as many
cars on the road
that said that's no reason for this to
be uh refused I agree with the office
completely and I'll be supporting it
thank you thank you um councilor bunting
thank you chairman yes is there a
parking issue in this area yeah there is
can it be put down to this and indeed
the applicant actually professionally
honest uh congratulate you on that point
that he was uh at least happy to admit
that point and not try and obfuscate it
in any way and is some of it down to
this institution yes is the majority of
it no as Council Thomas just pointed out
if it's uh dental service you know gone
tomorrow would the parking issue
suddenly resolve itself of course he
wouldn't you know so will people drive
to this dental practice yes they will
people generally tend to drive to that
especially if you're having dental work
done you maybe not feel so great
afterwards you're not going to want to
get on the bus immediately if unless you
can avoid it
will the increased parking as a result
of this change be significant in any way
or will it be a drop in the ocean
compared to the issue that's already
there yeah it is going to be the drop
isn't it so it's not going to make an
appreciable difference of any
significant kind that needs to yes so
yes there will be some harm but that
needs to be mitigated against the fact
that yes facilities like this are very
much required dentists are often in in
short supply and it's good to see an
expansion of a of a facilities such as
this so on on the whole I feel that the
any harms that are done are a extremely
limited and be overwhelmed by the
positives that come as a result of doing
of this application so I will be more
than happy to vote in favor of Officer
recommendation at aita Grant thank you
chairman
[Music]
uh thank you Council bunting any of the
members looking to speak Angela Welton
yes I'm very much in agreement with the
other members um I'm
glad to see that there's going to be a
travel plan submitted and I you know you
very much hope that they will be
recommending to customers as to to park
in the in in the mall and that's the
place the place for for people to park
if the parking is as bad as people say
they will and a lot of people won't be
able to park closely anyway so hopefully
they'll be encouraged to uh to go and
park where there are parking facilities
thank you
thank you councilor Welton yeah I think
I think the main issue here is is
obviously the parking and it's not for
the applicant to fix that parking
problem I agree with that and I think
the the expansion
creates a need for I think five or six
more parking spaces so that that's the
issue here it's those extra five or six
parking spaces which ideally will be
provided you're going to have trying to
park in that area and it is a
problematic area there's a lot of
businesses around there
um and so those potentially extra five
or six cars go into the site I don't
think that comes anywhere near saying
it's unacceptable
um in terms of Highway Safety or it has
a severe impact on on the road Network
appreciate what the um what Mr style
said that it's very easy to say it's a
highly sustainable location because it's
got a bus stop there
um and there are difficulties crossing
the road there I'm hopeful that will
change with the Redevelopment of
stretford marlin
um you know that we're more priority to
pedestrians around that area but I can't
see that those parking concerns give any
valid reason to to refuse funding
permission uh here
um so it has been moved and seconded
that we
um that we Grant planning permission as
per officer recommendation so we'll um
go to the vote on that now so all those
in favor of uh granting permission if
you could indicate no please
okay thank you that is uh unanimous so
that application is is granted
thank you
um
so we will move on now we'll just get
councilor Winston
so we'll move on now to
um uh Bowden Lawn Tennis Club
application 107 813 which is on page uh
one of the bundle and we'll start with
an introduction from Miss Coley
thank you chairman
chairman car park forming part of the
wider Bowden Lawn Tennis Club site the
site front green walk to the Southwest
for the remainder of the club stretching
to the Northeast and is bound by
dwellings to all other sides the site is
located within character Zone C Southern
residential of the devisdale
conservation area with the Revenge of
the tennis club site within character
Zone B the grade two listed building
earlstein is located in the southwest on
the opposite side of the road
the application the applicant seeks
planning permission to resurface and
reconfigure the car park to install a
gravel filled bod pave surface clearly
defined parking base two three meter
high aluminum LED lighting columns four
low light level light bollards and two
EV charging points the application is
being reported to the planning committee
as six letters of objection have been
received contrary to the office of
recommendation
given that the council's core strategy
Heritage policy is out of date The
Tilted balance in mppf paragraph 11d2 is
engaged
The Proposal is considered to be
acceptable in Principle as well as with
reference to design and Heritage
residential immunity highways parking
and ecology impacts the public benefits
of the scheme would outweigh the
negligible harms the conservation area
there will be no significant light's
Collision to residential cartilages and
the council's nuisance Consulting has no
objection to the scheme in terms of mppf
paragraph 11d2 it is considered that
with appropriate conditions imposed
there are no adverse impacts that were
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits of granting planning
permission as such the application is
recommended for approval
thank you there are no speakers to this
item so uh councilor Thomas I'll start
with you thank you chair
um a quick question can I confirm is the
column height on the lamp post 2.2 or 3
meters three meters okay
um well I'd like to see I'd prefer the
2.2 meters to be honest because it gave
me protects the residences
um a little bit better than three meters
and also like to have more to the glumbo
design and I'd like to have seen them
covered to force them to down light sort
of on the angle which light the uh car
park
um
adequately and again offer a little bit
more protection there to to pacify the
neighbors
um
similarly with the the walk which I
believe I'm
trying to think has they've been removed
now yeah yes that was never in the
application site so that's just been
removed from this game entirely but I
was going to say a similar thing there
uh hedgerows on the outside which are
outside again outside the application
then that's a thing for Trafford
environmental we should be making sure
that sports club we have the same thing
with the sports club in my ward where
they get around me by saying it's the
nesting season they should be doing it
just before and just after to stop
Pavements being done but that's no
reason to uh to refuse
um I think it's it's quite sympathetic
it gives the car park virtually the same
just with a little bit of lighting to
improve safety so I'm happy to propose
that we accept the officer
recommendation
thank you Council Thomas counselor
bunting
here we are again chairman how many
times have you been to this sites in the
past I remember actually you should join
our party lots of applications all of
them firstly contested every last one of
them here we um yeah so no surprise that
we've got uh in excess you have a
requisite number of objections to bring
this to us unlike cancel Thomas I I
don't have such a problem with the
design or the size of the the lighting
wasn't reasonable but that's probably a
matter of of of judgment I'm sure
medicine may agree some may disagree I
think the car I've been through all the
app for all the reasons for objection I
think it's more I think
I I don't I can't agree that any of our
for substantive reason to refuse it I
think it's more a case of antagonism
towards this site that is we get the
usual and you know anything you can
think of to object uh I I I I've I've
been through I can't see anything that
would stand up uh in terms of in terms
of any kind of appeal or any kinds of
scrutiny uh it's a perfectly reasonable
application and I'm more than happy to
Second uh the proposal that's just been
made thank you Kevin
thank you councilor Winston
uh thank you chair I can't judge the
antagonism of the the people who live
around the um we live around the club so
I won't I won't second what uh cancer
ponson just said uh but no I can't say
anything with this at all it I think
it'll add to the
um the facilities that are already there
I don't think it will do anything to
impinge on the residents and the bit I
did like about it is there'll be
additional lighting ritual
um Extended the extended hours into half
term which will actually make the car
park safer well again without impinging
on the restaurant so yeah I'm happy to
support this thank you chair
just picking up on that point
um the obviously there's concern about
the lighting and this has happened
before another similar applications
um
more of a technical question was there
any conversation with the club about
switching off the columns but leaving
The Ballad lights on after half nine
um not that I'm aware of counselor
I mean I was there's no reason to hold
this up but it's obviously it's just I
think um
worth is worth asking
um because I recognize why I recognize
in the report why
um you you have you haven't
um asked for the lights to be turned off
any earlier than halftime but uh that's
fine
thank you councilor Chuck can any other
members looking to speak
no okay it has been moving second to do
it we um Grant planning permission
um let's put it off the recommendation
so we will uh vote on that motion now so
this is to Grant well I was in favor of
grant you could indicate no please
and that is unanimous thank you
everybody
um so we'll move on to our last
application which is um
two George streets this is the former
Rackham store application uh double one
double zero six eight
starting on page 95 and we'll have an
introduction from Ms Lowes thank you
of the former rackham's department store
and Bentley's fish and chip shop at the
junction of George Street to Stanford
new road and Stamford way in Altrincham
and is cited within the Stanford quarter
Shopping Center
construction work is underway at the
site pursuant to a previous planning
permission which was granted by this
Committee in January 2022.
the site is located within the setting
of three conservation areas George
Street to the southeast Southwest
Stanford new road to the east old and
the old Marketplace to the Northwest the
site is also within the setting of a
number of grade two listed buildings
this application seeks to make various
minor material amendments to the scheme
and some changes to the internal layout
and to the external elevations and also
to expand the approved uses and within
the development to include a bowling
alley with ancillary uses
the proposed changes to the approved
plans include various external
alterations to the building this
includes um the facade reconstruction
and using a blend of reclaimed and new
bricks revision and revisions to the
external plant enclosure at roof level
changes to the brick Piers to make them
a consistent size within the elevation
and some further elevational changes to
respond to internal changes on the
Stanford way facade
changes to the approved internal layout
are also proposed including the
reduction in the amount of shower
facilities and cycle storage
the elevational changes are all
considered to be minor and the main
design intent of the development Remains
the level of cycle storage and shower
facilities still exceeds the council
standard and this reduction is
considered to be acceptable
the application also seeks to
um include the bowling alley use within
the development and at a lower ground
floor unit which was previously proposed
to be a food and beverage use
this additional use is considered
acceptable and a Leisure and
entertainment use will add to the Town
Center's offer helping to improve the
evening and nighttime economy in this
part of Altrincham
as previously included the development
will result in less than substantial
harm to the significance of nearby
Heritage assets the level of harm
identified as unchanged by these minor
amendments and again it is considered
that the public benefits of the scheme
without weigh the harm identified
when considering the development the
minor material amendments proposed by
this application do not change the
conclusions of the previously approved
Mission and the benefits of the scheme
significantly outweigh any harm that
would arise the application is therefore
recommended for approval and subjected
to appropriate conditions thank you
thank you Miss Lowe's uh no speakers on
this item any um counselor bunting
chairman I won't take very long probably
the easiest application of the evening
here causes any particular problem just
minor changes
you know uh so I can't really see any
object any reason to object and there
are no objections from the member from
people in the report either so with that
said I will just propose that we accept
officer recommendation thank you Jim
thank you cancer bunting councilor
Winston Stanley uh thank you to our
second that we accept officer
recommendation there's no substantive
changes it's a bowling alley instead of
where else is going to go in there it
will add to the um uh the Leisure
facility that offering I'm so happy to
Second thank you
thank you councilman Stanley uh I'm a
similar mind aren't you know I don't see
any problem with this application I
think the design changes are largely an
improvement to be honest uh it's a shame
that a lot of the bricks can't be reused
because I know that was one of the big
benefits of the original scheme that it
was going to recycle materials
um
yeah there's no there's no impact no no
different impact on on the Heritage
assets and uh I understand the
why the cycle storage has been has been
reduced because this is now part of a
more self-contained development and is
still well in excess of the of the
guidelines so I'm happy to support the
application as well
any other members looking to speak
no okay so it has been moving seconded
that we Grant permission as per the
recommendation
um so we will vote on that now please
follow us in favor of granting please
and that is unanimous thank you everyone
to that application is approved so that
brings us to the uh end of our
applications
um
we don't have any items of uh any of the
business so um with that we will uh
declare a meeting close so thank you
everybody thank you